[Music]
this morning a new book by podcaster and
author mike duncan his podcast on
ancient rome became a huge hit starting
more than a decade ago they've since
been downloaded more than a hundred
million times in his history book on
rome the storm before the storm was a
national bestseller
duncan has a knack for turning
complicated history into great
entertainment whether you're listening
or reading now he's turned his attention
to the marquis de lafayette with his new
book
hero of two worlds
this is the key to the bastille the
marquis lafayette sent the key to
washington as a symbol of liberty to the
patriarchal father of liberty if you
want a little taste of the marquis de
lafayette in america then mount vernon
george washington's estate just outside
the nation's capital is a good place to
start we feel that marquis lafayette
used that bedroom there during his 1784
stay and that is a portrait of the
marquis lafayette hanging there if
however you want the full story on a
figure who shaped the destinies of not
one but two nations
go find mike duncan his son lived here
at mount vernon with washington right
yeah
who was named after george washington
his name was georges washington
lafayette
it's an insane life he lived an insane
life he never stopped the guy never
stopped good material great material all
i had to do was write it down
duncan became obsessed with lafayette
while doing podcasts covering great
political revolutions in history when he
first arrived lafayette was just another
in an endless line of french soldiers of
fortune who showed up on congress's
doorstep looking for fame and glory and
honor so obsessed he told his wife he
wanted to move to paris to research a
book about four or five conversations
later we sold our house and we sold our
car and we sold everything that we owned
and we rented a place in paris and just
moved there and then when the book was
finished we came home you don't have a
history degree yet you become a famous
historian right
that is also a thing that happened
hero of two worlds chronicles
lafayette's life as a kind of forest
gump in the age of revolution a man who
always found himself in the middle of
epic events
marie joseph paul eve roche gilbert du
matiere marquita lafayette was born in a
french nobility in 1757 from an early
age it was clear he was not happy living
the stuffy life of an aristocrat his
first bold move was traveling to the u.s
when he was just a teenager to help the
americans fight the revolution he defies
his father-in-law he defies the king of
france he defies the the the considered
opinion of the aristocracy he buys his
own boat he sails to the united states
and he joins the continental army
lafayette was declared a general in the
continental army before turning 20.
early on he was wounded in the battle of
brandywine and while the americans lost
that round lafayette's bravery earned
him the notice of washington it was at
washington's side that he also weathered
a famously harsh winter at valley forge
and helped capture the british commander
lord cornwallis dealing a decisive blow
to the redcoats if lafayette had not
been part of the revolution would
americans have won the revolution we
know for sure that the united states
does not become a thing without french
assistance um the continental army is
not going to be able to beat the british
army and the british navy without the
help of the french lafayette was at the
very leading edge of official
recognition of the united states by
france and the movement by the kingdom
of france to support the colonies so
absent lafayette does france get into
the war
maybe yes but with lafayette there
absolutely
after helping the continental army win
and spending two long stretches in the
new world lafayette went home and in
1789 found himself in the middle of
another revolution
he supported the french people in their
quest for democracy
but unlike with the americans didn't
feel they were ready to fully abandon
their monarchy those split loyalties
came at a cost lafayette's great asset
was his perseverance his ability to
endure and continue to carry forward i
mean he almost gets his head chopped off
in the french revolution that doesn't
make him stop he winds up in a dungeon
for five years that doesn't make him
stop in 1824 lafayette returned to the
u.s visiting every state in the young
country while getting an official place
in the pantheon of heroes of american
independence there are hundreds if not
thousands of parks and cities and towns
across the country named fayette
lafayette fayetteville yeah there are
probably thousands at this point um and
this park was named after lafayette when
he was here in over 1824 in 1825. a
statue in the park facing the white
house was added in 1891. if he came back
and saw us today yeah he'd be very happy
he'd be very happy himself yeah and and
he would i'm sure give a suitably humble
speech about how it wasn't him it was
everybody together and he's just you
know he's just here and he loves every
minute of this
as debates around the country continue
about monuments to our nation's earliest
leaders lafayette's legacy and
reputation have remained largely intact
not just because you always strive for
the same ideals people still want today
like unity and equality
but also his position on slavery after
the war and after he goes back to france
he decides
that liberty and slavery are in fact
incompatible and that if the american
revolution is going to fulfill itself uh
and make the mark on the world and on
history that it needs to make
the americas need to free their slaves
and he
begins writing letters to his friend his
father figure george washington saying
you should set an example for your
countrymen and you should free your
slaves and prove to the world that
emancipation will not be the economic
ruin of the americas nor will it be a
moral catastrophe it will simply work
out well for everybody and he stays on
this for
the rest of his life the marquis de
lafayette lived his life trying to make
the world a better place surrounded by
some of the most significant figures of
his time
but as duncan explains in his
entertaining style
nobody's perfect there's two ways to
interpret lafayette um you know he was
this great and noble person with no
fault and then the other one is he was
he was a bumbling idiot who just screwed
everything up i've read both versions of
the story of lafayette and i just wanted
to kind of put those two together
because did he never make a mistake of
course not he was a human being who was
acutely self-conscious that he made
mistakes he certainly did not think that
he was perfect in every way and i think
that that's what
good biographies do is mix the good with
the bad and tell it all so what's the
truth what was he
i think he was a pretty good guy who was
trying to do the right thing and mostly
succeeded
my favorite history book i've read so
far really this year yeah he just said
duncan just has this approachable
easy-going style
and um the book moves i i just look
forward to picking it up every time
what's the marquis full name again yeah
yeah
i'm not gonna do that
oh it's here marie joseph paul eve roche
gilbert du monteir marquis de lafayette
we like it rolls right off the top very
good very good